you guys are obviously very young but
it's she the one like do you talk about
that yeah yeah yeah wait that's yours
lighting up I love this new movie it
comes out October 11th what did you love
about this project when you first read
the script
um oh yeah well I mean I was drawn to
the character instantly I thought the
character was really fine he was kind of
darker a little bit more mysterious and
also he was so passionate about about
about fans of him what you did but also
the added element of dance for this was
something that I've always loved in
films and also always loved doing
because adds that extra that extra
element I think it's okay it's another
amazing way to tell a story yes I was
really drawn to that you mr Turner I
don't need to see it again I can do the
turn Xander is very layered layered how
would you describe him
and yeah I mean definitely a layered
individual I think he needs to go to
therapy no yeah he is a he's obviously
very very very passionate about his his
craft and he knows what he wants to do
and he has this vision and that's it it
has to be that vision and if it's it
can't be anything else and so he's kind
of quite arrogant with that but it's
also quite an endearing quality about
that as well I mean apart from its quick
digression and stuff like that like
there is something that you can like
fall in love with you seem very opposite
of Xander yeah I mean I don't know you
well do you agree with that or do you
disagree
I am yeah I completely agree I yeah I
mean I think I I think I'm quite like
chill you were also in the descent
movies so you have singing dancing
background kind of talked about that and
why that worked in this film even though
we don't really see you dancing all that
much well I mean I am yeah I've always I
left school early because I was like I'm
just gonna waste my time here I'm
destined for yeah um but I was I was
quite young and so didn't think I was
ready for acting college so I went to
the mg Academy of Fine Arts in Edinburgh
which is like musical theater sure once
I did three years of musical theater
there and then obviously started working
for Disney and and that was a lot of
singing and dancing and then descendants
and so yeah it kind of seamlessly fooled
into high-strung which is quite good you
do have a song on this soundtrack it's
called masterpiece yeah yeah we
premiered the video for it did you write
the song I didn't know you didn't know
it sounded great you have a great movie
thank you very much do you see more
music in your future you know what I
would actually love to I just did a huge
series and called high fidelity yes and
I play a musician in that whose things
and so there are there's a few songs
coming out from that as well and I also
had to learn how to play a good time can
you play the guitar now I can yeah I
love it no yeah but your girlfriend also
very musical you guys start in
descendants together yes what do we have
lined up for you to work on next because
what we need to make us together yes
well we've talked about this a little
bit well here's the thing I mean
obviously wicked there's talk about
Wicked's
cooked of for Clint oh yes no one's been
mentioned in fear so is this is this the
official I'm just saying do you like to
start pushing it you know the play the
musical yeah oh I must have seen the
musical about seven times okay and light
on the West End I started but it's a
mess in and it's not once I'm Broadway
and I love it so you're ready for it I'm
ready yeah Steven whoever's gonna direct
we need to make this happen
what's your favorite song off the wicked
soundtrack mm-hmm I like I just put you
in the hot seat sorry no there's a few
I'm thinking I think that since real
life okay yes he's so happy
so good yeah for some reason I picture
you and Doug just like watching wicked
she just sings it she's just she always
sings yeah I know she's always singing
like was there did I stuff yeah but it's
same that I know popular you have a
stage how does doll feel watching you I
have to film romantic scenes because
there's a few kissing scenes in this
movie there is yeah um I mean everything
I've done actually this far has been
like I've had to kiss like I just did
Katherine agree with you got really good
reviews for that by the way yeah I need
to check it yeah sq.m but yeah I had a
intimate scene with Dame Helen moon as
you do that like by the way like she's
such a professional she's like he was
lovely person and really really labor
cuz obviously like you thank God Allen
Marion Lee but she's so so so
down-to-earth so funny I'm surprised
that she is down to earth because I do
think she's such a regal oh my god yeah
yeah yeah I mean she has that like
presents this kind of thing about her
yeah but it's not it's not it's not
negative it's not it's not like an
arrogance it's like I don't know it's
like a beautiful thing yeah and she is a
she's a she's also talented and but I
had a scene with her and that was she's
such a pro it was so chill and then I
had one with Zoe in high fidelity and
then I also have one with Julia in this
and what was your question how is it
she's fine you know it's it's our job
she gets it she gets it exactly and yeah
it is what it is we're both
professionals we both love each other
and trust each other so much is right so
it's not it's a little bit yeah how do
you deal with it you're fine with it I
am like it's really weird like imagine
if your partner it's like making out
with someone else yeah yeah is bizarre
but yeah I guess you just it's part of
the job and like I say we trust each
other love each other you guys have been
together what three three years three
years
when's the three-year anniversary it
just passed her it's coming up Shh
okay this is a really weird one because
we say the anniversaries in February but
we did start cracking on and like
October oh so it could be it's like
right around there do you celebrate do
you do anything we buy loads and loads
of doughnuts and pizza wait really
yeah yeah yeah you guys are obviously
very young but it's she the one like do
you talk about that yeah yeah wait
that's you're lighting up so of course I
mean she's she is just the most
incredible person I've ever met
she's so I mean I think people see her I
was so talented because obviously that's
how she that's her job to perform and to
all the rest of it but she saw she's
most compassionate and most patient and
most like genuine loving person I've
ever met
and it's so kind and so generous like
she's just amazing she really is yeah
and I and I always like sometimes I can
see people like beaming turn on social
media and stuff and it makes me suicide
because not only for her about so for
them because it's misinterpreted so much
yeah she's a lovely person she's so
lovely she's never bad born I bought it
no I mean we said earlier she looks like
a doll and she is a doll yeah I pull
this out tell those haters to just pipe
down what do you think people are gonna
love most about this movie when they
watch
hmm I saw them multifaceted words yeah
there's so much I mean if he if you love
dance you'll be drawn to but even if you
don't love dance you you'll still be
moved by it and there's the love
triangle and there's the individuals
goals like Barlow wants to become a
Broadway star and sign no one's become
this amazing choreographer and Charlie
what's coming so there's so many there's
so many dimensions going on so yeah it
just makes really like a really really
entertaining watch there is a theme in
this movie I would say we're you know
Barlow has these aspirations dreams if
you will and your character almost wants
a bigger name to play the lead have you
ever experienced that in Hollywood oh my
all the time really yeah of course all
the time I mean it's a nice song I
almost see it as like an apprenticeship
which I'm actually quite grateful for as
well because I think being able to guess
to you and guests here and then star in
this and like that's what I love love to
do mm-hmm and kind of almost Aaron you
just like London something massive
because you get to really develop your
craft as well which is cool I do feel
like a lot of people do know who you are
though because your Instagram what 5
million almost over again there though
we're almost there I'm gonna follow you
I'm I did look at your and I was amazed
by the engagement like you get just as
many likes as a Kardashian gets yeah
well that's it for me my managers here
we're gonna try and go down the Avenue
of Keeping Up with Donna do you read the
comments though
and I told actually I mean like
sometimes though within the first thing
I were because people are always like
see hi you're like notes mean you're
like I love you and so I will make like
a conscious effort to to like them or
like so yeah yeah cuz I mean like the
fans are they're amazing they're so
supportive
yeah like the like I know everyone says
the best but like actually the best
really involved yeah it's just so
supportive and like they just always you
know what's going on and they're always
yeah just really makes such a big
difference
sure going back to losing out on roles
to bigger names is there one that you
can think of we were like I really
wanted this but they ended up going with
Zac Efron it was sort of look like you
know what I always get who Richard
Madden yes yes like you don't understand
soon bison that's not embarrassed no I
was in I was in Burbank I was at
Starbucks and it go I was like oh my god
we think you are and the standards are
just coming in so look at English accent
by the way are American I should say and
I was like yeah yeah yeah it's me
edges that can I get a fool and I was
like yeah of course you can like doing
the whole thing and then I was getting a
four with you and she was like oh my god
I love doing Game of Thrones and I was
like wow this is so embarrassing I
didn't know wait no it's not me where
she's going around be like yeah yeah so
I get that quite a lot yeah well maybe
I'll start in one of the Game of Thrones
prequels that they're doing yeah they're
doing one oh I think a couple are in the
running why do people with you wanted so
your managers here right yeah let's put
the calls it what do you see for
yourself like is there a certain career
path that you are like I want to be like
a Leo or what do you see for yourself I
mean I think I think when obviously when
I started I was like I want to be
Leonardo DiCaprio like I love him I
think he's incredible and but I think as
you you start to kind of create your own
path you start to realize that is it's
such an individual experience it's all
you can't
there's no point comparing I'm never
gonna be the same and if you do compare
its oh you do try and achieve something
that someone else has achieved it's it's
not authentic it's not actually what you
wanted it's the idea of what you thought
that you wanted yeah and so as I kind of
keep working I do I have started to let
go of like expectations or like
comparisons yeah and have started just
to follow instinctively what what I want
to do sure and which is really
liberating and really free and it makes
you enjoy it much more and I as well I
think you can apply that not just to
this industry but like just to life in
general yeah and some an important
lesson I think no expectations and just
well more movies are more TV if you
could pick and I would like to do a the
next thing I would like to do a movie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]